what are some of the the biggest
challenges on the manufacturing side and
the engineering side that you're
facing in uh working to get uh to the
first launch of new Glenn the first
launch is one thing we and we'll do that
in 2024 coming up in this coming year
the real thing that's the bigger
challenge is making sure that our
Factory is efficiently uh uh
Manufacturing at rate so rate production
so consider if you want to launch new
Glenn you know 24 times a year you need
to manufacture a upper stage since
they're
Expendable uh every you know twice a
month you need to do one every two weeks
so you need to be you need to have all
of your manufacturing facilities and
processes and inspection techniques and
acceptance tests and everything
operating at rate and rate manufacturing
is at least as difficult
as designing the vehicle in the first
place and the same thing so every every
uh uh upper stage has two be3 engines so
those engines you know you need if
you're going to launch this the vehicle
twice a month you need four engines a
month so you need an engine every week
so you need to be that engine needs to
be being produced at rate and and that's
a um and there's all the things that you
need to do that all the right Machine
Tools all the right fixtures uh the
right people process Etc so it's one
thing to build a first
article right so that's you know we to
launch new Glenn for the first time you
need to produce a first article but
that's not the hard part the hard part
is everything that's going on behind the
scenes to build a factory that can
produce new L at rate so the first one
is produced in a way that's enables the
production of the second third and the
fourth and the fifth and sixth you could
think of the first article as kind of
pushing it it pushes all of the rate
manufacturing uh technology along you
know in other words it's kind of the uh
you know it's the test article in a way
that's testing out your your
Manufacturing Technologies the
manufacturing is the Big Challenge yes I
mean I don't want to make it sound like
any of it is easy I mean the people who
are designing the engines and all this
all of it is hard um for sure but the
but the challenge right now is driving
really hard to get to uh is to get to
rate manufacturing and to do that in an
efficient way again kind of back to our
cost point if you get to rate
Manufacturing in an inefficient way you
haven't really solve the cost problem
and maybe you're haven't really moved
the state-of-the-art forward all this
has to be about moving the
state-of-the-art forward there are
easier easier businesses to do I always
tell people look if you are trying to
make money you know like start a salty
snack food company or something you know
you you WR that
idea like make the Lex Friedman potato
chips you know this this is don't don't
say it the people going to steal
it but yeah it's hard you see what I was
saying it's like there's nothing easy
about this business and um but but it's
it's reward it's it's it's uh it's
fascinating it's worthwhile it's
meaningful and so you know I you know
not I don't want to pick on salty snack
food companies but I think it's it's
less meaningful you know at the end of
the day you're not going to you're not
going to have accomplished something
amazing yeah there's even if you do make
a lot of money out it yeah there's
something fundamentally different about
the quote unquote business of space
exploration yeah it's a for sure it's a
grand project of humanity yes it's one
of Humanity's Grand challenges and
especially as you look at going to the
moon and going to Mars and building
giant O'Neal colonies and unlocking all
the things you know I won't live long
enough to see the fruits of this but the
fruits of this come from building a road
to space getting the
infrastructure I give you an analogy
when I started Amazon I didn't have to
develop a payment system it already
exists it was called the credit card I
didn't have to develop a transportation
system to deliver the packages it
already existed it was called the postal
service and Royal Mail and Deutsche Post
and so on so all this heavy lifting
infrastructure was already in place and
I could stand on its
shoulders and that's why when you look
at the internet um you know by the way
another giant piece of infrastructure
that was around in the early I'm taking
you back to like 1994
people were using dialup modems and it
was piggybacking on top of the
long-distance phone network that's how
the internet that's you know how people
were accessing servers and so on and
that again if if that hadn't existed it
would have been hundreds of billions of
capex to put that out there no startup
company could have done that and so the
problem you know you see in if you look
at the dynamism in the internet face
over the last 20 years it's because you
know you see like two kids in a dorm
room could start an Internet company
that could be successful and do amazing
things because they didn't have to build
heavy infrastructure it was already
there and that's what I want to do I
take you know my Amazon winnings and use
that to build heavy infrastructure so
the Next
Generation you know my the generation
that's my children and their children
these you know those Generations can
then use that heavy infrastructure then
there'll be space entrepreneurs Who
start in their dorm room yeah like that
that would be a marker of success when
you can have a really valuable space
company started in a dorm room then we
know that we've built enough
infrastructure so that Ingenuity and
Imagination can really be Unleashed I
find that very exciting as they will of
course as kids do uh take all of this
hard infrastructure building for granted
of course the entrepreneurial Spirit
that's a um an inventor's greatest dream
is that their inventions are so
successful that they are one day taken
for granted you know nobody thinks of
Amazon as an invention anymore nobody
thinks of customer reviews as an we
pioneered customer reviews but now
they're so commonplace same thing with
oneclick shopping and so on but that's a
compliment that's how you know you you
you invent something that's so used so
beneficially used by so many people that
they take it for
granted